i have to you know be better i have to
leave this team better i got to protect
the football better we can't put it on
the ground the way we did um and it
started with me it starts with me and
i'm frustrated uh i know everyone's
frustrated with this with this loss
offensively i mean uh like i said
turning the ball over
starts with me i got to be better and we
will
carson wentz eagles quarterback a guy
who i thought was an mvp candidate
coming into the system if he stayed
healthy he stayed healthy definitely not
mvp candidate he's a candidate for this
week's goats in a bad way draft chris
you've got the trivia question that will
determine pick number one yep well and
nobody stayed healthy around him that
certainly affected that but here we go
lamar jackson made his case for mvp last
night we know that if he wins the award
this year mike he will be 22 years old
he would be the second youngest mvp in
the history of the nfl
who
is the youngest mvp
in nfl history
oh good guess
jimmy brown
very good guess though you're right i
mean that would have been one of those i
would have thought too gayle slayer is
the kansas comment when he came in that
was uh pretty special
okay where do i go i think i got to go
with carson wentz i am going to go with
carson wentz and again you know i don't
like this draft goats in a bad way okay
goats in a bad way we got to clarify
it's a dumb name first of all goats in a
bad way i'm just saying it all right i'm
transparent here goat means greatest of
all time right now but now we've made it
goats so i want to we should
shut up we should pick ourselves as far
as the dumb name for the draft okay shut
up and make your but i'm going carson
wentz yes you know carson wentz missed
some throws in that game and i know it
was windy the other day uh but hey you
know there was just a few throws where
you got to make it he makes some bad
decisions led to some bad turnovers you
know the pocket collapsing a few times
and just almost being you know i don't
wanna he's too fearless at times in the
pocket you know we've talked about how
he you know injury plagued history and
things like that because he plays so
physical he needs to have a little bit
of a you know somewhat of a governor in
his brain to go hey i'm sitting here for
three seconds i've patted the ball four
times nobody's gonna come open magically
after that move get out of the pocket
don't stand there don't let them do that
now i'm picking carson wentz but i also
think you know doug peterson gets
involved in this conversation a little
too because they got to reinvent
themselves like we talked about with
sean mcvay on the offensive side of the
ball too it's just nothing special what
they do how many times can carson wentz
jamming a six yard completion
so the help's not there but he's not
helping himself either uh and that's why
i'll lead off with him
yeah i'm gonna start with and i'm
shocked you did not i am shocked you
didn't take this guy jason garrett how
can you not take jason garrett yeah that
would have like 27 hot takes 27 hot
takes about how badly he screwed up
things but from not being prepared for
the elements right yeah they knew it was
going to rain they knew it was going to
be windy they knew it was going to be
cold they seemed thoroughly unprepared
for what they were dealing with so
unprepared the dak prescott didn't have
a glove on until midway through the
second quarter and ezekiel elliott's out
there with a bath towel
did we not pack sufficient hand towels
and we have to run out there with a bath
towel that they brought from the hotel
so they could be properly prepared the
the decision to kick the field goal
instead of go for it on fourth down when
it was late in the game six minutes left
and they were close to the goal line
yeah all sorts of just the list goes on
and on gets called out by his owner we
don't need we don't need any help
identifying jason garrett as a goat his
owner set that one on the tee for us
after the game on sunday night so what
do you think i'm an app you're i don't
know i'm an absolute idiot that's what i
mean i wrote it down i got stars next to
it you're right i mean not going forward
on fourth down was just a travesty that
was the bonehead move you know whoa it's
13 to 9.
you know what you still need a touchdown
so i just that was not good and then yes
him and kellen moore with all the third
and threes and running and throwing the
ball
uh with the patriots having one and two
defensive alignment on the field that
was inexcusable i am an absolute idiot
for not picking that first i got too
caught up in the carson wednesday there
i'm gonna go with the packers offensive
line as being one of the goats of the
week i mean the packers offensive line
if there's one thing they're supposed to
be able to do is pass protect a little
bit you know hey they've been running
the ball better this year but i mean
when i turned down that film yesterday
that was just a that was a slaughter
session they just got run over by the
the san francisco 49ers did i know brian
balaga got hurt it didn't matter he was
in there to start the game when they got
run over from the start there as well it
was just hey you know nobody opened down
fields certainly but i mean a lot of
times plays didn't really have any time
to develop anyways because the dam broke
so quick aaron rodgers couldn't really
pull the trigger if he wanted to pull
the trigger he knew he was going to be
in danger of somebody hitting him just
as he threw it and it might be a fumble
so that was really disappointing the f
the fight got tooken to them they were
not ready to answer the bell and they
got dominated up front
yeah you know it was one of those games
it was so bad who do you make the goat
right there are so many different
candidates and that same vibe influences
my next pick because just like in the
sunday night game it was a blowout it
was a horrible performance by the
packers monday night horrible
performance by the rams who do you pick
right you're right
you're right do you do you go with jared
goff how much of it is it was jared goff
out there getting blown off the line of
scrimmage no right not always
sean mcvay i mean sean mcvay's the
expert on the offensive side of the ball
who delegates all of the defensive
responsibilities too and this is not a
popular pick because everybody loves
wade phillips but i'm sorry you got to
own it when you get blown out like that
he did not have that defense ready to
face the ravens whatever they did or
didn't do they were not ready if aaron
donald's going to get smothered by
multiple 300 pounders have them rush
from the outside move them around do
different things come up with something
have your guys ready they allowed
themselves to get mentally and
physically broken by the ravens and
wade phelps been around long enough he
had to have seen this coming it's got to
be on him at some level for a total
failure of defensive performance and
total failure to meet the physicality
and if you know they're going to be
physical you got to come up with
something else it's got to be on him
he's the guy that gets all the praise
when that defense plays well when they
get blown out like they did last night
and they never even have a chance on
offense it's because their defense did
nothing and they got jaylen ramsey what
do you get would you go trade for jalen
ramsey for when the other 10 guys can't
do anything and we know who aaron donald
is when you take away aaron donald and
you don't throw at jaylen ramsey and
you're basically
conceding those
the other guy the other nine guys should
be able to do something and they could
do nothing last night and you know and
instead of picking a player or just
painting with a broad brush and putting
it on mcvay i got to put it on wade
phillips i hate to do it but i got to do
it yeah i i hear you i mean i think you
know you're right it's hard to pick one
in that massacre we saw last night uh i
also think the interesting conversation
there is what are they gonna do with
jaylen ramsey what are they going to do
jalen ramsey going to watch what is he i
think james is going to want to get out
is he going to want to stay there he
might be like yeah you know things don't
look that great in the future here you
guys have uh sent away a lot of first
round picks i might just run out of town
and you can eat those two first round
picks that you use to get me so uh that
is going to be very intriguing going
forward i think my last one is going to
be the raider skill guys specifically i
want to just go with like the wide
receivers and the field goal kicker more
than anything you know the game was a
34-3 blowout new york jets yes the game
was only 13 to 3 at half there was a
missed field goal in the first half and
there was a number of big drops by the
raiders tyrell williams and hunter
renfro they looked like two guys that
were like oh gosh it's the northeast and
it's cold and rainy and it's 10 o'clock
back home i'm not supposed to be playing
football and it was just not a good
showing so they had chances early in
this game to make it a game and it was
some of those big drops that led to the
then blowout along with the field goal
kicker missing it and all that i don't
really want to sit here and blame it on
derek carr uh he did some good things so
yeah i'm going with them because as what
tony dungy said the raiders looked like
a california team that didn't want to be
in northeast weather in november and
they just wanted to be home cozy in
their bed
well but why why and and i'm just
curious because i was i had derek carr
on my list yeah why did you choose to
absolve him well i know that i'm totally
absolving him i know he wasn't perfect
but man i can remember two like tyrell
williams going down the middle of the
field perfect throws that were dropped
that were gonna be 20 30 40 yard
completions i remember hunter renfrow at
least on one third down and then there
was another drop i don't know what down
it was it was a third down drop he was
out on the right ran like a slot out
route it's gonna be a first down early
in the game he drops it they end up
getting you know nothing there there was
another one a little later in the game
so yeah derek carr certainly was not
perfect but i i just from watching that
game and i didn't watch the film i
thought the the wide receivers really
let them down and then the field goal
kicker missing a field goal early on
where they could have gone in the half
only down a touchdown and that changes
the game
yeah speaking of field goal kickers i
got to go joey sly the panthers kicker
for now he may not have that job much
longer good one he missed two extra
points and he missed that 28 it's a 28
yarder i know it's 28 yards right and he
missed it now who knows what the saints
would have done they still would have
had a couple of minutes get down the
field maybe tie the game or win it but
you put yourself in position where they
have dudes go down the field and they
kick the field goal and they walk off so
joey sly i don't think he's gonna be the
panthers kicker much longer but uh for
now he gets the goat horns coming out of
week 12. all right let's recap and let's
take a break and we can talk more about
the monday night game the good stuff
from the monday night game when we come
back chris selected carson wentz do we
won today here we go
carson wentz the packers offensive line
and the raiders skill position players i
got jason garrett wade phillips and joey
hey man you had the you had no they
asked me the ridiculously difficult
trivia question that i almost got
and you get the first pick and you blew
it so thank you totally blew it thank
you you took trubisky and you left my
homes on the board thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports